il est président de la république et en
même temps en campagne pour sa
réélection vous voyez de qui je veux
parler bon en fait emmanuel macron n'a
rien inventé
[Musique]
on va faire un bond de 10 ans en arrière
on est à la fin de l'année 2011 nicolas
sarkozy termine son quinquennat il n'est
pas encore candidat mais il fait des
placements sur des placements sous
l'oeil des caméras et ça forcément ça a
le don d'agacer ses concurrents les plus
président de la république il est
candidat en permanence qu'il le dise
qu'il se déclare officiellement donc on
distingue bien ce qui est de l'ordre de
la prise de parole de l'action du
président de la république avec celle
d'un candidat en campagne et du côté de
la droite à l'époque on fait comme si de
rien n'était on trouve ça normal un
président président et peut préparer sa
réélection c'est le jeu je trouve que
c'est une polémique d'une stupidité sans
nom
c'est comme ça ça a profité entre
guillemets à françois mitterrand 1988
là où c'est bien on imagine bien que
nicolas sarkozy sera en février candidat
mais il faut lui laisser la capacité
d'être président le plus longtemps
possible
évidemment nicolas sarkozy pense
beaucoup à sa réélection et pas qu'en se
rasant alors en janvier 2012 ils
organisent une grande interview
présidentielle diffusée sur pas moins de
six chaînes de télévision ça rend fou
les socialistes et aux questions
gouvernement l'hémicycle du sénat
devient quasiment un ring de boxe six
chaînes de télévision
les principales
traditionnels ou du service public
toutes les chaînes d'information à la
même heure à l'heure de plus grande
écoute aucun français ne pourra y
échapper
il pourra zapper d'une chaîne à l'autre
il devra il devra subir la parole
présidentielle
franchement vous n'avez pas beaucoup vu
la télévision durant l'automne où nous
avons eu droit à un programme de
télé-réalité particulièrement réussi qui
s'appelle les primaires socialistes
qui nous ont permis ils nous ont permis
qui nous ont permis semaine après
semaine de savoir qui reviendrait en
deuxième semaine je ne sache pas non
plus que le formidable show paraît-il de
la rock star du bourget est échappé aux
téléspectateurs puisqu'il a été très
largement
il a été très largement distribué la
rockstar du bourget vous l'aurez reconnu
c'est françois hollande souvenez vous il
avait organisé le premier grand meeting
de cette campagne présidentielle au
bourget avec le fameux mon ennemi c'est
le monde de la finance on connaît la
suite en 2012 c'est lui qui rentre à
l'elysée et cinq ans plus tard on n'a
pas pu reprocher à françois hollande
d'être à la fois président et candidat
puisqu'il n'a pas pu se représenter
[Musique]